state department will now take the lead
more than six thousand americans have
been evacuated jesse tanura is in
washington tonight with more
good evening the white house just said
that president biden will be addressing
the nation tomorrow but in a statement
he did say that this was the unanimous
recommendation from his joint chiefs and
the commanders on the ground
i'm here to announce the completion of
our withdrawal from afghanistan a
surprise announcement from the pentagon
20 years in the making to end america's
longest war the operation has gone
smoothly so far but u.s centcom
commander general kenneth mckenzie says
real threats from isis could have
changed that and the taliban helped
secure the airfield to make sure the
last u.s troops and officials could
leave safely they were actually very
helpful and useful to us as we close
down operations general mckenzie reports
since august 14 u.s troops evacuated
close to eighty thousand civilians from
the kabul airport including six thousand
americans but they had to leave some
behind it which stayed another ten days
louie we wouldn't have gotten everybody
out that we wanted to get out and there
still would have been people who would
have been disappointed with that
secretary of state tony blinken says
about a hundred americans including
long-time residents of afghanistan who
hold u.s passports still could want to
leave for many
it's a painful choice
our commitment to them
and to all americans in afghanistan and
everywhere in the world
continues but lincoln says for safety
the diplomatic mission will move from
kabul to qatar given the uncertain
security environment and political
situation in afghanistan
it was the prudent step to take
now the taliban have said they will
allow normal travel to continue once
they take control of the airport but the
biden administration is proceeding with
caution on that live in washington i'm
jesse tenor back to you